roberto fue a casa de su amigo que
estaba a un kilómetro de distancia de su
casa cuando él salió de su casa comenzó
trotando hacia la casa de su amigo y
luego caminó el resto del camino el
trozo dos veces la distancia que camino
que tanto camino escribe la respuesta en
metros así que vamos a tomarlo paso por
paso pensemos primero en la distancia
que toto así que digamos que esto de
aquí es la distancia que trato ahora el
camino la mitad de esta distancia así
que vamos a dividir esta distancia en 2
y luego tomamos la mitad de esto y esa
es la distancia que él podría haber
caminado así que esto verde es el total
de distancia que trato y luego el camino
la mitad de eso camino camino justo la
mitad así que esto de aquí para hacerlo
más claro la sección verde
esto que estoy coloreando de color verde
esta sección de aquí va a ser lo que
trato y esta sección blanca es cuando el
camino entonces esto es cuanto el camino
ahora si observamos esto y sabiendo que
esta sección blanca es la mitad de la
sección verde puedes ver que la
distancia total esencialmente ha sido
dividida en tercios donde el trozo dos
tercios de la distancia
trotó dos tercios y luego el camino un
tercio de la distancia y esto es
consistente con lo que está escrito aquí
pues un tercio es la mitad de dos
tercios o dos tercios es dos veces lo
lejos de un tercio el camino de
recorrido de un tercio ahora cuál es la
distancia total y bueno ellos nos dicen
que es un kilómetro un kilómetro por lo
que la distancia total de aquí es un
kilómetro pero luego ellos quieren que
escribamos la respuesta en metros así
que en lugar de estar pensando en
términos de kilómetros vamos a pensarlo
en metros y sabemos que el prefijo aquí
lo significa 1000 por lo que
literalmente significa 1000 metros estos
son 1000 metros así que si quieres saber
qué tan lejos o qué tanto camino roberto
pues el camino un tercio de la distancia
y la distancia total fueron mil metros
así que que tanto camino camino un
tercio de los 1000 metros un tercio de
mil metros y entonces cuánto es un
tercio de mil metros y pues hay un par
de formas en cómo puedes pensarlo y lo
puedes pensar como un tercio por mil un
tercio por mil lo cual será igual a mil
tercios los cuales literalmente pueden
ser representados como están así simple
mil tercios o bien esto también puede
ser visto como mi dividido entre tres
que es la parte en la que está dividida
el kilómetro o si estás tratando de
encontrar un tercio de 1000 puedes
escribirlo déjame escribirlo así como
mil entre tres y si tienes mil y lo
divide entre tres
cada vez tres veces y en diez nos sobra
restamos y nos sobra una bajamos el otro
cero otra vez cabe tres veces lo
restamos y nos vuelve a sobrar 1 bajamos
el siguiente 0
y luego otra vez el 3 cada vez es veces
en el 10 pues 3 x 39 y restamos y
tenemos 1 de residuo y puedes decir bien
esto es 333 y sobra 1 o puedes decir que
aún el 1 está dividido entre 3 que es lo
mismo que decir que es
333 y un tercio a lo que voy a escribir
que esto es igual a 333 y un tercio
metros y esto es lo que camino en metros
333 un tercio metros y aquí lo dejaré